so all the things that you uh that you
do to enjoy yourself and for work with
your DJing whether it's uh acting acting
exercises even maybe maybe you exercise
you learned when you were fighting right
do you incorporate that into a daily
routine
uh not always not as as regimented that
there's elements of that I like to do I
always want to play something you know I
think when we're kids we spend a lot of
time playing and that's how we discover
we learn in the playground whether it's
at school but we're still playing our
mind's always uh sort of trying to
discover stuff and we do it through play
so as an adult we sort of forget to play
you know and for me I enjoy that so the
creative arts as an actor you do get to
play a little bit you know because
you're always imagining your characters
whether it's Luther or whatever it is
you're imagining and that in some ways a
form of play but I do try to do stuff
that's fun
um exercise-wise I mean I have this
theory that if you imagine you're doing
10 press-ups
it's the Mind muscle connection you're
like oh yeah that just worked out really
hard yeah I'm working too hard I just
got to think about it more like you do
that 10 mile run I just did in my head
oh sorry if you can mentally get
yourself to sweat then that's that's
half the word the body doesn't know the
difference that's it appreciate it
um so you know we're talking about play
Luther is a very serious guy and it
seems like
um it seems like very serious work but
does it feel like play at what moments
when you're doing this character does it
feel like play
um does this character to play as an
actor is very uh demanding you know
detective work and murder detective work
is no fun and it's it's horrible
actually you know to walk into a crime
scene and have to reverse engineer what
happened here that's Grim that's like
living through not only someone who's
the victim but the someone who's the
perpetrator as well so that's a grim
space to be in
even as an actor even though I know I'm
not playing that role you sort of want
to be as realistic as you can so it's
difficult it's not fun however what is
fun is that you know John can say one
line 50 different ways you know what I'm
saying and all of them can be
interesting and
you know shift the way the story's told
and that's what I find interesting so
with Neil cross the writer his way of
writing things you know he'll say okay
the blue is the sky is blue today what
do you think and John could say that in
so many different ways and where I love
playing is like how can I say a line
like that and make it really John
luthery and just change the inflections
and change the stresses just to make it
a little bit weird and that's what's
something that I found a lot of fun to
play with John
you've played this character for years
now and I know that there's a bit of you
in John and there's some John in you
have you become more like each other
like are you more like John now or is
John more like you now
um I think I'm more like John now and
John in this show and this film he's
like in a vulnerable state you know he's
had his stripes taken off him uh he's
taking his he's had his freedom taken
off him he's been thrown into a den of
wolves and they all want blood you know
and he's vulnerable he's not scared but
he's vulnerable I think that you know
I've climbed my career
for 30 years I love what I do but as you
is you know as it goes on I get a bit
vulnerable it's like oh my God when's it
going to end you know what if what if
I'm not as creative anymore but what if
I you know don't have the passion that I
do one day and it's a vulnerable state
to be in you know
the the the the the the similarly though
is that he loves what he does and so do
I yeah and that's just once you get into
it this is no looking back there's no
sort of idea of stopping there's no
vulnerability that would ever sort of
dismantle me as an actor or him as a
detective
so you've been
you know a working actor for decades now
which is an accomplishment and of itself
but we're you know we see you all the
time getting accolades and getting a lot
for so many things whether it's again
your acting career or any of the other
million things that you're doing
this is why he's not doing 10K runs
because he's thinking about doing the
run but he's busy doing other things
when was the moment where you were like
people know me now
people like I'm walking down the street
and they're and they know me they know
my voice they know my face
uh weirdly enough I think it's
comes in Cycles you know what I mean
because even though we are
um you know people in the public eye are
public eye they're not always in the
public eye okay do you know what I mean
they might be you know oh you know even
if it's a musician I love that album but
then if you haven't heard from them for
another while then you might walk past
them in the street because they're not
in your conscious State you know and
that's similarly for actually like if
I'm not
in a film for a while people might just
walk past me quite easily
and so uh for me hey it's me no no no no
so you know
I think there's like a
a PR team always say you're kind of
three years on three years off
because the cycle of making something
and then it coming out and then
everyone's like oh yeah that was great
or whatever it is you're doing a press
tour and then you you're back to work
and your mind you're in a back to work
cycle it takes a while before you're
back in the press cycle so recently for
me which is a long way to answer this
question recently for me you know it's
been more aware that
you know everywhere I go there's someone
that goes oh and that's really a new
thing for me you know as long as I've
been acting I go to different countries
and it's like oh you know you recognize
me so you know I was in um
I was in uh what else oh my God that was
somewhere and I was like I can't believe
that I'm being recorded I think it was
somewhere in France somewhere like right
somewhere in Europe I mean I just didn't
realize that they would have you know me
on their radar and you know and so more
recently it's become a thing that's
interesting to me that you would go
somewhere and kind of be surprised that
you'd be on their radar yeah because I I
don't presume that everyone knows who I
am even though I've been acting for a
long time you know when I look in the
mirror it's just a guy
that was trying to be an actor you know
so if I walk into a restaurant in the
middle of Belgium I'm not expecting
everyone to recognize me but when
someone does it's like oh oh whoa that's
just it you know what's super
interesting in in this film there's a
scene where you're you're shooting a
Piggly circus right and that's like the
most populated place you can be all the
tourists are there everybody is there
there's business there's fun happening
whatever yeah but you got like for your
movie for Idris movie
you cut you shut it down yeah and you
did the thing there
the young version of you that's looking
back in the mirror that's like trying to
be an actor what does that guy think
about all that yeah he that's like what
yeah how did you get here it's like time
travel yeah because you know I look in
the mirror every morning I'm like ah
same old guy but you know here I am
suddenly you know being able to shut
down uh Piccadilly Circus to make a
movie based on a character that only
I've played you know that that's
definitely fascinating
um I think my younger self would think
wow you yo you actually made it
whoa
tell me how it is you know what I mean
yeah
that guy too is I mean he's about to be
a DJ as well like he's doing a lot of
things you you DJ before you yeah
Forever on uh on screen yeah DJing was
my sort of First Love First sort of
performance yeah if you like I I did
just since I was 14 and
um you know what's great about djan is
that it never changes you know what I
mean you stand in front of an audience
and they were like
you know you have to entertain and um so
that that feels the same you know even
as you get sort of higher up in the DJ
hierarchy it's still the same sort of
pressure
gotta entertain I love that is that
nerve right like is it more
nerve-wracking to get out there in front
of a crowd that you're not entirely sure
is is right yeah than to be on set it is
yeah because on set you have you know
the sort of procedure of being able to
do it again yeah perfect it do it again
differently do it again but you know
when you go out and do a two-hour set
you just have two hours you know what
I'm saying and you know yeah you know
this set of Records worked for the last
party but it might not necessarily work
for this party so it's always different
but you know I just love that feeling
even though I always say I'm like oh my
God why am I nervous before I DJ but as
soon as I get out there it sort of goes
away yeah do you have any uh any songs
any tracks that you have to slip into a
set like this is no not really that's a
that's a very common question and I
think everyone's different you know what
I mean I think there are styles of DJing
that always make you know an audience go
for it like you know you know playing an
acapella and everyone's like oh I love
this acapella and I'm waiting for the
beat drop as a style is a great way to
always get the anticipation going
um obviously mixing records where people
don't feel the seams and then they hear
the bass drop that's always a there's a
great transition when you're in the
crowd I guess a crowd member and the DJ
is just on it and just there's nothing
like it and I can I can see why like you
would want to go back all the time like
you still have the residency are you
still uh I I had a residency last year
yeah this year I'm not doing that I'm
filming a bit more but I'm I'm sort of
doing Coachella this year doing Winter
Music Conference in Miami doing a couple
of festivals here and there when you DJ
the wedding of Harry and Megan who was
the best
dancer who like what celebrity out there
really had the moves oh uh do you know
what I was so nervous at the time
I think Megan was the one that was
really learning letting it go you know
she was a real um she just had a lot of
fun it was her wedding so she had the
greatest time